this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode he's looking at the world
war ii era weaponry of the tactical
shooter hell let loose so this is the
ptrs 41 it's hard to convey i think
how enormous this thing is
if you're interested in seeing more
world war ii error firearms make sure to
check out our videos on battlefield 5
and call of duty world war ii if there
are any other games guns and mechanics
you guys want to see jonathan break down
let us know in the comment section below
and if you'd like to help out the royal
armies museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
okay pause well we're off to a good
start there with the browning automatic
rifle the m1918a2
this is well modeled well implemented i
think they're running on the
slower of the two rates of fire makes
you realize listening and listening to
that and watching it how you know a
well-trained soldier firing rapidly you
know semi-automatic can easily match
that sort of low 400 rounds per minute
or 300 and something i think it was the
other sort of minor nerdy detail is the
lack of the carrying handle which is
also correct because most of the a2s
you'll see now as well as probably
having their bipods will have a carrying
handle on them which is another kind of
moving toward like machine gun thing
well that feature was not fitted during
the second world war so these guys have
done their research it's well modeled
it's well represented apparent recoil
rate of fire all of that seems to be
pretty good and the effect on target as
well you know firing bursts short bursts
of twos and threes as you probably would
be doing and the enemies going down so
there's none of this bullet sponge
nonsense
the classic mg34 looking good so far
okay so we've got uh two mg34 gunners
here i suppose an ongoing quirk of video
game bipods is that they don't really
engage with the game world
as they perhaps ought to um it has to be
fudged to allow you to place the gun and
move it around so our second gunner that
we see here is floating in space because
he's he's in the prone animation but
he's on a sloped surface and it doesn't
quite work but it gives us a good view
of the in-game mg34 which is looking
good i think looks a little short there
i think that's probably just uh
perspective the position and hold of the
gun which is you know something you've
got to pay attention to when you're
modeling something like this looks right
i mean i don't have a german manual to
handle anything but it looks period
correct
the house
these are going up
nice
right so we're going house to house now
or into a house and the gunner is
holding the bipod legs together as a
sort of improvised forward grip which as
far as i know was done you need
something to be able to hold on to that
cooling jacket isn't going to stay cool
for very long not with a 900 rounds per
minute plus rate of fire which is um
again correctly implemented as far as i
can as far as my ear can discern
now we've got the the drove machine gun
the d
p
this is the second light machine gun
i've seen and it looks like they're
preventing you from shouldering the
thing from from aiming using the sights
while shouldering the gun which is
realistic in large parts and prevents
you from just running around running and
gunning like it's an assault rifle which
i suspect is the main reason they've
done it so i do approve of that but you
will always find stories of absolute
units that would shoulder a bren gun or
something similar similar size and
weight to this and actually use the
sights if you had sufficient upper body
strength you could fire this thing from
the shoulder but i i definitely approve
of that as a gameplay choice because it
reflects the real world use of the thing
yes you can hit fire it yes we're gonna
see more hip firing than we should in a
game and the primary role is from the
bipod and that's what we're seeing most
mostly here in the footage reloads look
good on the dp all i would say and this
is true of almost any light machine gun
but especially one with a big cumbersome
pan magazine like this is that reloading
on the run as we saw just now just not
possible you can't run with a big heavy
gun like this and
maybe unless your assistant gunners
running alongside you and handing you
the mag and then even then getting that
located on the gun one-handed and
properly seated well i'd like to see
someone try put it that way
we've got the german car 98k as we'd
expect to see in a second world war
shooter some interesting gameplay there
quite a straightforward scenario where
you've got an enemy soldier that's
somewhat zigzagging toward the shooter
who with a bolt action rifle is
desperately trying to score a hit of
course with a self-loading rifle you
could fire more rapidly and ensure that
you scored that hit and of course that
totally reflects reality this is a
limitation of the weapon that's being
modeled it's a bolt-action rifle what
are you gonna do there's only so fast
that you can fire this thing so i'm
intrigued to know how it plays perhaps
you know let us know in the comments how
frustrating it is to go up as the
germans against an enemy that might have
a self-loading rifle
we've got the m1 carbine the recoil
looks a little excessive to me the 30
carbine is a sort of glorified pistol
cartridge really and does not produce a
huge amount of felt recoil even in a
light carbine like the m1 carbine which
matters of course in terms of your
dispersion of fire that might have been
done deliberately to
balance the thing so something i think
i'm picking up on here is that where as
you move and i've seen this on a couple
of recent games the the iron sights are
moving in relation to each other as as
they
would and i would assume that when you
are pulling the trigger the bullets
going wherever the front sight is
pointing so you actually do have to take
account to some extent of what your
sight picture is maybe that doesn't pan
out in the gameplay at all but it got me
thinking and it's one of the main things
missing from for enthusiasts like me
where site alignment and site well site
picture fine you can you can you have to
get a side picture to hit what you're
aiming at you have to lead your target
all of that but site alignment is not
usually a consideration there aren't
enough controls on a controller or you
can't really get your fingers around the
controls to both realistically aim a
weapon and point your upper body and
move your feet and do all of that within
a game
our old favorite the m1 garand or garand
or m1 rifle if you'd rather avoid the
pronunciation issue looks pretty good so
far but right out of the gate i noticed
and i happen to have
one of ours here
that it's i won't say suffering from
but has the same issue as just about
every other second world war game that's
had the features of the garand in that
the rear sight aperture is absolutely
massive so the one on
the real gun
is one and a half mil something like
that but it's a much smaller aperture
and that is that is what allows you a
degree of precision in the use of iron
sights it focuses you right down on the
front side they
they must have done this deliberately as
have call of duty battlefield everyone
else who's ever done the garand because
your sight picture would be so cluttered
as to be frustrating i think that's the
reason why but it does mean that it's
slightly inaccurate a bit of a myth
about the m1 and the fact that you can't
top it off you can't add more ammunition
but i think what they're getting at when
they make that criticism is that you
have to eject whatever's in the gun and
load a complete eight round clip but in
fact that's not the case with a bit of
practice you can eject the clip retain
it in the weapon insert extra rounds
into the clip and push the clip back
into the rifle what we see here is the
well it's one it's one up from the games
that wouldn't let you even eject a clip
we've moved on from that but we're also
throwing away a partial clip to make
matters worse actually what's happening
is a regardless of how many shots the
guys fired a full clip of eight rounds
is what's flying out of the gun so
that's just a that's just an oversight
that i'm sure will be addressed at some
point i always feel bad for pointing it
out so a you wouldn't waste valuable
ammunition and b you don't magically
reacquire all eight rounds because if
you could do that you just leave them in
the gun i think
yeah there's a guy in the left-hand side
of the tank by trees
we have our friend the mosin rifle so
the the rifle in its scope looked pretty
good to me um there's a glaring issue
with the reticle which is correct it's
the the three posts one pointed post and
then the two either side that's the
correct reticle but the fact that the
reticle is stays still as the scope and
the and the rifle recoil once you once
you notice it is extremely distracting
and it's just an oversight i'm sure they
will improve that in due course but
suffice to say that the reticle at this
era is on a piece of glass that is
inside the scope and should be moving
with the scope the i think more
interesting than the representation of
the rifle here is the way it is the way
it's being used so we've got i don't
know if this happened organically or if
it was planned but we have the sniper
with his mosin and we actually have a
spotter another player who is
working with the sniper lying in the
grass with him using much more powerful
binoculars and certainly this era they
are more powerful than the standard
sniper scopes to see what's going on at
distance and identify targets
working as a sniper spot a pair and the
second world war was really the the
origin of that modern practice of having
two-man sniper teams but it's just nice
to see some gameplay that reflects real
military doctrine because it works in
both realms you know it makes sense low
magnification of the scope means you
either have to make do and be less
effective or someone helps you out with
a pair of binoculars
i have to say the uh the ppsh or
publisher whichever you prefer what he
won looks like a lot of fun to use in
this game it's a combination of the the
very high rate of fire but also
controllability so that 762 by 25
cartridge is kind of the sweet spot for
ballistic effectiveness and
low recoil energy now i like the fact
that the player is actually is cupping
the drum off to the side which is how it
was actually shot with the with the drum
fitted because you can't really hold it
otherwise extremely awkward to perform
the reloads with this it's always going
to be easier to just press a button and
watch it happen than to fumble with it
in real life so the the feel of this is
really good i think the week they've
kept the recoil the sort of perceived
recall low you can with a bit of uh
mouse control clearly keep the reticle
on target for an entire magazine which
you absolutely can do with the with the
paper shirt so that's great but we also
see that the player is defaulting mainly
to short bursts which is still more
effective yeah if you're kicking in a
door or something you might you might
give it a long burst but for
effectiveness and ammo conservation you
want to be firing short bursts which in
this with this thing is you know
delivering three to five
rounds of 762 at a very high rate
uh counterpoint to the paper shot is the
german mp40 which they seem to have
nailed i have to say so it's got that
slow deliberate rate of fire but very
low recoil i mean that thing must be the
the lowest recoiling submachine gun that
i know of just kind of sits there
chugging away largely because it has a
big telescope spring buffer in the
receiver that slows that bulk group
right down it's a good implementation
the mp40 is iconic enough that people
are going to notice if you if you get it
wrong it looks good it works well i am i
know i'd rather have the ppsh though
so this is the ptrs41 it's hard to
convey i think
how enormous this thing is and i don't
think and it's not the game's fault but
i don't think you really get the sense
of how big and heavy it is either yeah
these these things absolutely did get
used against personnel what we see here
is a sample sap in the open getting
engaged by the ptrs and they go flying
like a like a skittle i still don't
think that would happen the way we saw
it he was a bit too ragdoll there in
reality this thing is traveling at such
velocity that it's certainly not going
to do you any favors but it's going to
zip through you but with 14.5 we're
getting to the point where you actually
are getting knocked off your feet
potentially by around that big and heavy
it's as close as you're going to get to
the classic movie flying through the air
thing
the stg storm
this is looking good except that i've
just realized i don't believe you can
change fire mode that very good long
range shot there so at least you can
perform those would have had to have
been a tap of the button which is fine
but you'd be able to focus a bit more on
trying to use it as a rifle if you were
able to switch it to semi-automatic only
and it would be more
faithful to how the gun is actually
operated having said that um if it's too
good a rifle an infantry rifle
substitute you're really going to make
the car 98 the players hate the car 98
so maybe that's a conscious choice to
make you exercise a bit of your own
trigger control to pull off single shots
so i'm not sure how the game implements
the the issue of this rifle as it were
but due to
limited quantities and
some tactical reluctance for from the
german armed forces especially hitler
himself the stg ended up issued to
assault
platoons
so so almost everyone in that unit would
have a stronger bear now
for a game like this you kind of do need
to limit the availability of this thing
somehow otherwise everyone will just
have it and or you have to nerf it
really badly because you have to make
the other weapons worth using
the thompson of course has to make an
appearance
in this context and we have the m1 or
m1a1 in this case though it's wrong
because the site protector is okay but
the sight within it is a weird sort of
square u-notch and i don't know where
they've got that from because the
sight
on the m1 and the m1a1 is a simple
l-shaped piece of metal
with a round aperture in it it's
possible they've chosen this to increase
the player's field of view in the iron
sights but i don't think so because the
sight they've chosen instead is much
wider than the actual sight on the gun
and if they just wanted to increase
field of view they could have just
locked the top off the proper narrow
site that should be
there
i don't know if it's just perspective
but it seems the gun seems a little
small in the player's hands uh scaling
is an issue with 3d models in games in
the aim this looks about right so i it
could well be perspective but the whole
gun seems a little slight for me the
thompson is is a large heavy gun
thank you it should be directly three
ton
um we've got a series of firearms videos
over on the royal armouries channel that
you might like to check out as well up
in the description of this video there
are links to our donation scheme and
also our membership scheme here at the
royal armouries museum if you'd like to
support the work that we do either way
i'll see you again next time
[Music]
[Music]
you